yes Father this is a question as
monitoring teachers
is very important and
also we have to talk about monitoring
teachers and training teachers at the
same times you know and sometimes you
know especially when you come to the
lower limited schools you know you would
find that the students or the pupils
knows more technology than the teachers
and here where we start having problems
you know so i think yes we have to have
very clear policy and monitoring
teachers and training teachers but
before all of that also i think it's
very important to look at their car door
in itself you know and the values of the
teachers you know i remember 40 or 50
years ago we used to hear that you know
the status of teachers and the status of
professors probably is different than
the status of them today you know so I
really would like to take this
opportunity participating in this forum
to ask and to probably request more
importance in really investing and
education I have talked previously and
used a code by Bill Gates when he said
we invested a lot and technology but
probably we have not invested enough and
the people who are going to use this
technology which means in education in
man powering you know so yes I do agree
with your question and I think it's very
important you know
to monitor everybody you know monitoring
students monitoring teacher to know